Напередодні четвертої річниці катастрофи MH17 на Донбасі
міністри закордонних справ країн Великої сімки знову закликали Кремль
відзвітувати про "свою роль" у катастрофі малайзійського "Боїнга".
17 липня 2014 року у катастрофі авіалайнера рейсу MH17,
що летів з Амстердама до Куала-Лумпура, загинули 298 людей.
Що вдалося з'ясувати через чотири роки після трагедії?
Міжнародна слідча група з розслідування кататсрофи MH17,
до якої входять експерти з Нідерландів, Бельгії, Австралії, Малайзії та України, встановила,
що літак збили із зенітно-ракетного комплексу "Бук".
Лайнер зазнав аварії в результаті детонації боєголовки,
яка вибухнула за межами літака з лівого боку від кабіни пілотів.
У результаті детонації передня частина літака відвалилася,
літак, по суті, розпався в повітрі.
Зенітно-ракетний комплекс "Бук", з якого було збито літак рейсу MH17,
належав 53-й бригаді військ протиповітряної оборони Росії, базованій у місті Курськ.
Такі висновки Міжнародної слідчої групи.
Експерти проаналізували всі світлини, що зафіксували пересування цього "Бука"
до полігона в окупованому сепаратистами Первомайську.
За даними Міжнародної слідчої групи, вистріл з "Бука"
був здійснений з підконтрольного сепаратистам Сніжного.
Свідчення жителів міста, які стали очевидцями запуску ракети,
записали репортери західних інформаційних агентств,
а також команди журнілістів-розслідувачів Belligcat та Correctiv.
За час розслідування Міжнародна слідча група
поки не називала конкретних імен винуватців авіакатастрфи.
Це має бути наступним етапом слідства.
Тим часом у дослідженнях міжнародних журналістів-розслідувачів фігурували кілька імен,
зокрема тодішнього сепаратистського ватажка Ігора Гіркіна,
російського відставного офіцера Сергія Дубинського
та генерал-полковника російської армії в запасі Миколи Ткачова.
Нідерланди й Малайзія ще три роки тому намагалися домогтися створення
міжнародного трибуналу ООН щодо MH17.
Утім, Росія цю ідею ветувала.
Тому замість міжнародного трибуналу відбудеться Спеціальний суд щодо MH17 у Нідерландах,
швидше за все, в Гаазі.
Якщо будуть винесені обвинувальні вироки,
Київ зобов'язався привести їх у виконання на території України у випадку,
якщо засуджених не видадуть Нідерландам.